Okay. So, um,
just want to go back very briefly
to the title of as I lay dying.
As you guys know, the
title is taken from, uh,
the other save book 11 and um, is, um,
Agamemnon is, um, has gone
to the underworld and his,
uh, dcs has gone to the underwear
and he's talking to Agamemnon power,
who's telling him about the circumstances
of his death and his murder by his
wife are collecting the astro.
So as I lay dying,
the woman with the dogs,
I were not close my eyes as
I descended into hades. Um,
so this is the original,
um,
inspiring moment in many ways of four,
four,
four Faulkner.
And today I like to talk a little more,
um, about the whole of modernism
and the epic tradition.
Um,
and obviously we see with red enough of,
as I lay dying to know that this
is in many ways an epic journey.
It is a journey, um, very
heroic or mock heroic journey,
uh, to Barry. Addie, you, so is,
it has all the trappings of the APIC
is an epic journey on a small scale.
Um, and it's also, uh,
taking advantage of to epic conventions.
Um,
we've seen just now that we hear the
voice of the debt and that's a very
important adding a convention
both in homer and in downtown.
And as we'll see,
um,
it is also a very important
convention in as I lay dying as well.
The farmer is making very liberal use of,
um,
the other interesting epic conversion
that I think has been involved in as I lay
dying is the uncertain boundaries
between the human and the nonhuman.
And we have already actually
seeing a little bit of that.
So just wanted to refresh your memory
with something that we discussed last time
in terms of the two kinds
of speech right now.
Last week we talked about the social
dialogue on the one hand and then on the
other hand, the worst with secrets. Um,
and this is one instance of worst
with secrets coming from vitamin.
Um,
so this is vitamin talking about something
in the bond after he has been beaten
people these horses and broken the
state. Um, it is as though the dark,
we're resolving him out of his integrity
into an unrelated a scattering of
components,
snuffed things and stamping smells of
cooling flash and ammonia hair and the
illusion of a coordinator,
the whole large,
high and strong bones within which
drange and siblings and Somalia and is
different from my yes.
Um,
most likely vitamin is talking
about the horse by this weekend.
See as, especially as we get
closer to the end of that has, um,
this being that is drenched and secret
and familiar and is different from mine
is vitamins things to be talking
really more about his brother Joel,
then about Jules horse.
Um,
and it's really hard to
say when the human and,
and when the animal begins in that
particular passage. So this is,
um,
something that we see both in the kind
of a small moment like this and as I lay
down,
but also in the very dramatized Merwin
when volume and says my mother's a fish,
uh,
where obviously a strong analogy is
being established between human and
nonhuman. We'll come back to
that statement, um, on Thursday.
But today I like to,
um, just to go back, um,
a little bit and give you a sense of
this very long epic tradition behind as I
lay dying by going back to
hormone and Dante and, um,
in [inaudible] I want to talk about
two instances. Um, the side clubs,
obviously we don't know
if he's fully human.
Um,
and,
and even more famous episode is
Searcy attorney humans into animals.
And then Dante following through
with that convention in Inferno, uh,
when humans are turned into animals,
there's punishment. So first of all,
homer in book, nine of the artist say, uh,
Odysseus and his men are trapped
inside cage by the side clubs. Um,
and the way that they tried to
escape is by blinding aside clubs.
Polycythemia is,
and so this is a moment that is reproduced
by just about all the painters who,
uh,
paying that seen that episode in the
Odyssey is the blinding of the eye.
And we know that cycle of the lands
one eyes. So it's relatively easy.
It's the only have to do at once.
Um,
so here's is ucs blinding
eye of the cyclops.
And we can see that, um, the
cyclops themes bigger, you know,
the main difference seems to be in size
and also the amount of hair on him. Uh,
but otherwise he seems,
he looks he's a human form.
But we also know that it's different if
only because there's one either in the
center of his forehead. Um,
so he is not quite human,
but his close enough and
that is a condition that is
especially fascinating to
epic authors. Um, just give you a
couple more images of the cyclops.
Basically. You know, it's the same,
same kind of idea. He's much larger,
um, has a lot more hair but otherwise
has a recognizable human form. Um,
three far the man trying to um,
use that spike to blind side clubs.
And here is one more image.
Um, so it's pretty much is that there
seems to be kind of consensus, um,
in thinking about is high clubs
that he really basically is like us.
But what is also interesting is
that after his eye has been blinded,
um,
decide,
labs wants to make sure that when his
ship leave the cage that they wouldn't be
humans. Hiding, uh, going along with them.
So it's counting all his sheep as
they go out, as they leave the cage,
even though he his cave, even
though he can really see them. Um,
and he surprised that his favorite shoe
is the last to go and he's the last to
go because this is clinging to him.
But this is where science club says
to his sheep, sweet cousin Ram,
why lab behind arrests in the night cave?
You never lingo so,
but Grey's before they're more
and go far to crops, wheat,
grass and take your stays
there were leading along the
streams until an evening.
You come to be the first one in the fall.
Why now so far behind?
Can you be grieving over your masters?
I,
so this is, um, not only is, um,
a sense of is there a sense of kinship,
um,
between the side gloves and his shoes,
but this is one of the earliest moments
of a cross species identification that
decide clubs obviously is
mourning the loss of his eye. Um,
and his imagining has proved jetting
that grief onto his shit and recreating
kinship on a different level.
Not just on the physical level,
there's a connection between humans and
animals, but also on a psychic level,
on an emotional level,
there is that kind of kinship.
So the other thing I would say,
it's one of the earliest moments of
really interesting kind of cross species
imagination at least in
this one moment. Um, so, um,
the more better known moment,
and actually I would argue
with less siloed than theirs
is the transformation of
humans, um, by, uh, Cersei and here's at,
this is going after her because she was
transformed one of his men into, uh,
animal.
Um,
so we see many instances of this
arm and this is an amazing, um,
image. Uh, I mean this kind of vessel, um,
with all the animals, uh,
and [inaudible] house.
And I think that we recognize
that actually there's a
strong Egyptian influenced,
um,
this image is loafer Egyptian and there
is in fact a constant traffic between,
uh, Greece, ancient
Greece and Egypt. So, um,
it's partly that the impetus
for thinking about humans,
they're not humans is coming from, it's
coming from [inaudible] as well. Um,
and he has just to complete our discussion
of the Arabic tradition that Dante is
doing the same thing.
And I just wanted to alert you that
the snake is very important. Um,
the connection between the human
and nonhuman in the inferno, um,
is that Dante is basically
punitive philosophy, um,
is that humans get punished by being
changed into something that resembles the
crime.
So thieves because there's Nikki in
the snake their way into other people's
dwellings and of text
book belongs to them. Um,
that fears are turning
into snakes in the info.
So lots of snakes in there.
Further off,
and one more dramatic representation.
All these are by William Blake. Um,
so we kind of have a really interesting
congestion of a 19th century author
going back to Dante and reproducing
this very emblematic moments.
Um,
so there,
so we have on record in 19th century
author William Blake being inspired by the
epic tradition.
And I think the foreigner is a 20th
century instance of a similar kind of
inspiration, but as we're Faulkner, um,
he as a,
another layer of complexity
to the epic tradition.
And I would say that this is actually
one of the most important innovations.
And as I lay dying,
um,
in many ways more interesting than the
epic journey itself is that humans are
rarely identified with
just one kind of animal.
More often they are poor between
two ends of the spectrum.
Um, they sometimes identify with one and
sometimes identified with the other and
sometimes it's a mixture of the two.
So the two parents rooms that I would
like to talk about in that context,
um, uh, first is first of all a how, um,
and then Jude,
how was a minor character,
but in many ways he's a really
good example to concentrate on,
um, to try to get a sense of the
basic narrative strategies, um,
in Faulkner.
So I would just like to stop here for
a moment and talk about possible paver
topics.
Um,
when you think of the upcoming long paper,
um,
is to focus on minor characters.
It is counted to they,
um, to use minor characters, um,
as the main subject of your papers.
But actually, um, I promise you,
especially in the case of fogging or you
can get wonderful papers by focusing on
focusing on someone liked how, uh,
or even someone might Cora, uh,
very, uh, obvious entry point,
but because they are an
obvious Andrea points,
you can actually end up writing really
interesting and surprising and compelling
papers.
Um,
so I'll try to give you a demonstration
today of what could be done by focusing
on a minor character lighthouse and
then obviously moving on to central
character Joe.
So I like to argue that toe is basically
identified with two opposing kinds of
animal. One is the mew,
um, the indispensable, um,
animal amount, poor waste, the
meal rather than the horse. Um,
and then, um, Aphasia.
They'll also mixed a routine
appearance in Falkland Deposit.
So first of all, the
new and how as new, like
when I look back and my new,
it was like he was one of
these spy glasses and I
couldn't look at him standing
there and see it all abroad land.
Am I house sweated out of it?
Like it was. The more the sweat,
the broaden the land,
the more the sweat,
the title of the House because it would
take a tight house for Cora to hold Cora
like a job.
Nope.
In the spring you've got to have a
tight jar or you need a power spring.
So if you have a big spring,
why,
then you have the incentive to have tight,
well make jars because it
is your milk sour or not.
Because you would rather have milk that
was sour than to have milk that won't
because you are a man.
I've no idea what he's talking about.
Um, this, this is really, you know,
I think maybe it's just the sound of
it that thought that was, is to, um,
get the flavor of thoughts that might
have been causing through tells head.
It's just a wonderful moment
and talking about manhood, um,
amount more ways.
Um,
people who don't have a lot to
prove the man who went right middle,
fast, no cars, no iPhone was nothing. Um,
so very,
uh,
poor equipment with which
to prove your manhood.
And the only thing that,
um,
tell can use, um, is just his view.
And so he's looking at his meal and
by looking at his knee and somehow his
thoughts neander to the most important
person in his life, his wife,
Laura. Um, and is,
that is his claim to core out.
So I won't be able to tell you,
you know,
the logic behind this
little bit of reasoning,
which is really more emotional reasoning.
There was a reroute reasoning,
but it seems that how is
saying that his claim to Cora,
the way that he can keep her,
keep her in a tight house, um,
both in his,
the physical house but also in a tight
place in his heart and in her art,
um, is by being a very
good neighbor, by sweating,
um, and cultivating the land, um,
and making sure that the more the sweat,
the tighter the house,
right.
So this is the logic that this
is the nature of manhood amount.
Four ways is that it is by this web of
your brow that you can win the woman's
call. You know, it's nothing
fancy, nothing complicated,
various simple logic.
But of course,
it doesn't come out in a
simple way and Faulkner, um,
and that really is kind
of the defining nature of,
uh, the existence of very
poor, rural people, um,
is that basically you only have
one thing, um, to prove yourself.
And we can see that why on
this one thing as a such an,
an adequate specimen of masculinity
is just not a very good workman.
Um, so how is by contrast,
someone who was fully adequate,
fully competent,
fully impressive specimen of manhood
in that particular environment.
Um, and he's very proud. You know,
this is a very joyful moment.
This is one of the great
scenes about marriage.
And on Thursday we'll talk about
contrasting scene of a very bad marriage,
contrasting with his head,
very happy seeing of, of, of,
of a married couple in Faulkner.
Um,
but as we're father
millstone stay happy forever.
Uh, oh, humans that are like
meals don't stay happy forever.
So we're turning to a
different meaning of the news,
uh, when the journey takes, um,
both an athlete but also a tragic
turn when they try to cross the river.
When the bridge is gone, um, and
the museum as well as the pool.
Um, the, the, the, the
call across the river,
which they know they cannot do.
So they are just looking at
this impending disaster. Um,
and once again,
the meals as emblematic of people who
know that something terrible is going to
happen, but with absolutely know
how to stop that from happening.
The Mayo stand, the fourth
quarters already sloped a little,
the realms high, they
do our breathing. Now,
the dean who groaning sound looking
back once the gays sweeps across those
within the eyes are wild,
sad profile and despairing quality as
though they had already seen in the thick
water the shape of the disaster,
which they could not speak
and we could not see.
So I think the anti convention,
um,
is in fact the entire ancient Greek
physician is involved in two ways,
both in,
um,
the muse as in many ways
and the medic of humans. Um,
but also in the function as a
tragic corals, right? You know,
that this is a structural feature of in
Greek tragedy, um, chorus looking on,
um, knowing that the
catastrophe is about to head,
but with athlete and no
ability to prevent this coming.
So that's what the meals are doing here.
That's the function.
That's the ethics function within this
La di very much associated with a kind of
reassigned but resilient attitude,
um,
that we're seeing with, um,
that we're seeing the towel.
But in this case the resignation
and the kind of pose no bravery,
um, the dose to holidays unrelated,
adequate to stopping, uh, the,
the,
the arrival of a catastrophe.
So in the next moment we sort
of see what happens to the news.
Um,
and this is in many ways in
play a logical conclusion of uh,
what they have already been aware of.
Um,
this is a completely unsurprising,
um,
ending to this sequence began by the
Muse as to tragic corridors between two
hills.
I see the views once more,
they roll up out of the
water in succession,
turning completely over the legs.
Stiffly extended as when
they had lost contact with,
they were.
So this is in many ways a backward
gesture to that burlier happy moment,
uh,
when the Muse of fully contended and
fully capable of doing what they can do
that then they all environment muse
are creatures with feet of clay.
That's was clear.
And this kind of sequence is
that because they are creatures,
we're feet of clay,
they can only survive when
they are on solid earth.
And when they own solid of,
they are very good in making that
Earth projective and reproductive.
Um, so this is really what, how is
talking about is a very improved delta.
The farmer,
he's also reproductively happy with Cora.
Um,
that is the nature,
but also to limit of a new
lighting systems is that
there are certain lines that
Muse cannot cross.
They cannot transcend the own condition
as creatures with feet of clay.
They can only be okay. They,
and it really is no more than that.
They can be okay only within one setting.
And in this other moment,
uh,
when they left, the
customer is setting, um,
and they'll start trying to
negotiate with a swollen river. Um,
we know that the muse will not survive
in that kind of transformed setting.
So in many ways,
the perfect analogy for the poor wise
that they can do relatively well when
they're left to their own devices,
when they allow simply to
stick to the environment.
But once they are taken
out of the environment,
then we know that terrible things are
gonna happen to them. Um, so in, in,
in this particular sequence, um,
how being associated with the Muse,
um, he's basically defenseless. Um,
he wants just to be allowed to live,
live according to his own fashion.
Um,
that really is the basic requirement of
the muse is to be left alone and to be
allowed to, uh, just to survive
as they, as they know how to do,
um, that is a very innocuous, um,
and in many ways have very sad portrait
or poor ways, but basically innocuous.
But family really also has a somewhat
different image of whether poor white
community,
my amount to,
and so he's not just going to give
us an image of pool wise as defense.
There's, but basically non aggressive,
right? Abuse a completely non aggressive.
Um,
Faulkner does thing that the Ashley is
an element of aggression in a very close
knit community,
especially the close knit community
such as the poor white community.
And we see that in the next
image of the parole ways. Um,
coming from,
not surprisingly from jewel,
this is how you things about his neighbors
and now them others saying they're
like buzzers waiting,
fanning themselves,
every bastard in the country
coming in to stare at her.
We've talked about hatred as a very
important emotion as the kind of emotional
bond within the family.
And we now see that hatred is also a
very important emotional bond within a
small isolated community.
Um,
not only does to hate someone like
tell because they always think they are
watching your every move,
not only those Jew hate how,
but he also imagines that there
is an element of aggression,
something that is not quite benign
coming from the neighbors. Um,
and that is really why he said
suspicious of them and you know, so, uh,
it be disposed was them
on his part. Um, and I,
the bosses actually will appear over
and over again for this thing. And,
um, the sound of theory, uh,
the buzz was collecting, uh,
around the body of the dog,
Nancy in the ditch. Uh,
and buses that band j imagines
would go and undressed is dad,
grandmother.
So buzzers have already appeared in
[inaudible] but in SLA dine buses as a
physical presence would
be quite important. Um,
and also as a metaphor,
a president to talk about what your
neighbors might really be like in the
hearts,
not in our behavior but in the hos.
They might be just like buses
and he has an image. Awesome.
The buses to explain why. Uh, Jim, I
think that the neighbors are like them.
So,
um,
towers I said it's not obviously not
the main protagonists in as I lay dying.
Um,
but he is an important clue to what
Faulkner is trying to do because the way
Faulkner portrays very important character
is almost exactly analogous to the
way he portrays.
Tell excepted what in,
how is dispersed and sequence.
Um,
tell is sometimes identify with the neo
and sometimes identify with the buzzer.
We don't actually see him being
simultaneously identify with both.
Um,
what is sequence and spaced out in town
would quite often be collapsed together
as one and Faulkner's
portray of [inaudible].
So in this moment we actually see
Julie being a lichen to two of animals,
not just one, not just his hose,
which is obviously the main creature.
Um, that is a fully that with, um,
not just the words, but something else
come here.
So Joe says he moves
moving and quit his code.
Bunching,
tongue swelling like so many
flames we're tossing mean.
And to enrolling I the horse makes
another shot in rush and stops again.
Feet Bunge watching jaw,
jaw while stellate what him,
his hands at his size,
say food, Jews legs.
They are like figures.
Coffered her blow savage in the sun.
When jewel almost hugged him,
the horse stands on his hind legs and
slashes mean of WHO's as by an illusion of
wings among them.
Beneath the up rear Chaz,
he moves with a flashing limberness,
a snake for instance,
before the Joe comes into his arms,
he sees his whole body.
Earth three horizontal.
We're paying snake limber until
he finds the horses nostrils.
And of again,
so many things to say about this moment.
The first,
and we were referenced back to the news
and the fact that they are creatures of
clay,
is that Faulkner is based in the king
of very deep metaphoric distinction
between two kinds of animals.
They're animals like the muse who can
swim and can only survive when they are
honest, solid earth. Um, and
then there are other creatures.
The horse being the main example,
um,
who actually can leave earth
for non trivial length of time,
um, and they are able to survive
when they're not touching the earth.
So right here we know that Q is a very
different kind of person from tower.
Yes,
he is in a white,
poor white community or his
parents appeared to be poor white.
But for some reason there is something
else about [inaudible] that makes him
different, um, his more
horse life than you like. Um,
so this is a kind of a
backward reference, um, to, to,
to another input an animal in SLA dying.
But within the compass of
this particular passage,
what is really interesting
is the simultaneous cope
presence of the horse and
the snake. And for those
of us, the two of them,
Ashley really are not that have light
coming in. And it's hard to think of,
you know, any kind of kinship really
between the horse and the snake. Um,
they look different and they have very
different connotations. Um, you know,
in our common understanding
of those two animals.
So let's try to see what it is.
Then there was Faulkner,
um, to bring those two
animals together. Wellbeing.
We know that the horse
is the winged horse.
So this is going back to the epic
physicians in illusion with wings.
This is not just a hose that
is, um, uh, earthly creature,
but seemingly one of the wing
hoses of Greek mythology. Um,
and certainly the causes acting,
uh, like a method because, um,
in that emotion, um, it's almost, uh,
beyond just the physical capability
of any earthly creature. Um,
so it is,
um,
the body in motion but not being register
as body lor but simply as bodily pause
coming into view when suddenly you are
seeing that bodily part but not really
the entire horse.
And that actually was the way the father
and was thinking of the horse as well.
Right in the, if we go
back to that moment, um,
in father representation
of the Horse in the barn,
um,
it was as though the dark where resolving
him out of his integrity into an
unrelated scattering of components.
So nothings and stampings,
smells of cooling flesh and have
all their errands a lot. So, uh,
vitamin has exactly the same
kind of scatter a representation.
The horse is moving so fast that
we're not actually seeing or was, um,
as a single integrated being
but simply as different barley,
barley pause,
coming into view through emotion.
So really is less about the
body and as a part of his body.
Then about a kind of very fast and
with transcending kind of version. Um,
and that is really what,
um, how Jews who was,
is represented to us.
We don't see him as a horse.
We simply see him as something
that is in constant motion.
But more than that,
it is the very and beggars relation
between Joel and the horse.
Um, obviously you lost
his horse, you know,
he's done a lot of work to get the horse.
It is very much his horse.
Um,
but it was not exactly an
affection relation, right?
Was,
it is a battle between two creatures,
very important.
Each other are the horse probably is
the most important creature to jewel.
Um, but there's no fashion
there. So what is the feeling,
what is the emotional bond
between these two things? Um,
it is not common factor, which
is the most ordinary and, uh,
easily recognizable and
recognize human bond, um,
is not there.
What is this other emotion that is there
and it seems that we're thought new
suggesting is that instead of the common
human affection is a snake like quality
that is binding cure to his horse.
Uh,
we don't know what emotions, snakes, um,
they're not credited with having
emotions either sneak in those,
which isn't really an immersion.
Um,
so we don't actually know what kind of
emotional bombs can come from snakes
abrasion or maybe simply of
hatred, but you know, but that is,
that is a kind of a general, general
thing. Um, it's not a benign, um, feeling,
that's for sure.
So right now let's just say that
we don't completely understand,
uh, what is going on here
or why this snake is afraid.
Put a supplement to the
relation between jaw and horse.
Um, we're bad ones again to what
we've been talking about earlier,
which is the narrative as a
secret bearing narrative register.
There's another social dialect.
This is with secrets.
That's what we're saying right here.
Um,
and just to highlight how unusual this
description of [inaudible] and the horse
is, just want to go back very briefly
to a contrasting moment in Hemingway.
Uh, when, once again,
we see a human pair with an animal that
was very important to him in our time.
Um, this is the, or killing the
ball. When he started to kill it,
it was all in the same rush. The ball,
looking at him straight in front,
hitting the ball charge
and filotto charge.
And just for a moment they
became one for the other,
became one little ball
and then it was over. Um,
in this passage in Hemingway,
actually the emotion,
the emotion of patrons is
quite important as well.
So in an odd way,
just like Faulkner Hemingway's
also interested in hatred
as a powerful emotional
bond.
Um,
and that really is what
enables to go fight to go off,
but it is hatred so clear and so
transparent and so ritualistic.
And so ceremony is that it is also a
transform by that ritual into the Commons
love really. So, um, and
Hemingway, it is very,
very clear as the clarity of the,
and that is in the foreground,
there's really nothing more to say.
The ball and the matador has become one.
Hemingway keeps repeating that everything
is completely clear and there is no
secret whatsoever.
By contrast,
this is a secretive narrative,
um,
that flaunts his secret in our face.
We don't really understand what's going
on and that is the prevalence of this
kind of narration. So, um,
just to refresh your memory were
drawn inspiration from Frank Vamos,
a classic genesis of [inaudible] and um,
the moment where Foglar is highlighting
and dramatizing the existence of a
sacred is by way of Joe's horse.
And this time is the fully dramatize
moment in the sense that not only is the
horse, they are not only Joel there,
but everyone else is there. So this,
the entire tragic chorus,
uh, or maybe in this case,
not completely a tragedy either,
but the entire chorus is there witnessing
this dramatic exchange and it is no
longer an exchange between Ngo
and the horse. But someone else,
Joel Masa looking at him,
I give,
give, give. Then she began to cry.
She cried hard not hiding the face,
standing there in a faded wrapper
looking at him and him on the hose,
looking down in her,
his face growing cold.
Those slick looking until you loved away
quake and cash came and Tajay you go
onto the house, cash said, does he have
grounds to West for you? You go on.
Now that night I found master named
decided bed where he was sleeping in the
dark. She cried a whole lot,
maybe because she had to cry.
So required mainly because she
felt the same way about tears.
She did about this seat heating herself.
We're doing it,
hating him because she had to.
And then I knew that, I knew,
I knew that as playing as part
of the day I knew about do the,
so is the moment when the secret is
exposed and is exposed of course without
thought they'd ever coming close to the
very simple nature of that cigarette.
Um,
it is completely by way of this,
the tour around Joe's horse,
the way we know that there is the secret
is that ad his response to a horse is
nothing like what would have been a
normal response to [inaudible] sun
disappears and night after night, you
know, people don't know where he goes. Um,
and then all of a sudden he
comes back with his horse. Um,
[inaudible] hood of
possession amount more ways.
Muse would be to stand the Alamos
to half a poor ways of horses,
not at all the thing to have
or that anyone could have.
So, um, this is a procession, um,
that is inappropriate for Paul Weiss.
Uh,
vitamins response is what
would it have been an ordinary,
completely understandable responses.
Let me ride a horse.
So volume it is reacting as anyone would
react and his response is by crying.
Um, which I guess is, could still
have been normal except that
the response then from too
is that his face is growing Cole.
And then he's looking at her
and the more he looks at her,
the more sick looking he becomes.
So that is not in the script at all.
If the horse had been anything
but a good event,
right?
If the pause has simply
been a joyous acquisition,
none of this would have happened.
So what is it that transforms a joy's
acquisition into something that people can
either cry about,
I'll be very uneasy about,
or something that requires
some degree of confidence,
which is what cash seems to be
doing here is this proud mother. Um,
and add a ought to be a proud mother
and instead cash is talking to her as if
someday to terrible had happened to her.
Go on back to the house,
go on now to ground is too wet for you.
The solicitor,
you coming from cash
is also an explicable.
So we can say that from every single
person to overreaction of addy,
the crying,
the sake looking expression on Jews phase,
the over illicitly or coming from cash.
All of those things are things that should
not be in the script but surprisingly
are in the script.
And then we know that there really is
something that could be named that can be
identified and named. And even though, um,
dow is not going to name it for us,
he comes as close as he
can to saying that word.
Uh,
so the way he tells us is that I knew
that as playing on that day as I knew
about do it.
Hell.
So right here we see a kind
of bad word reproduction. Um,
in terms of farmers characterization,
we know about doing nails pregnancy
out of wedlock first, right?
And this is the thing that Dow those
about is transparency with it is duly dose
out of wedlock pregnancy that is
being reproduced in her model.
This is the kind of interesting backward
reproduction like mother like daughter.
Um,
and in this case we know
about the daughter's condition
first and it's because
now is exactly the same reaction now in
exactly the same degree of knowledge.
Now that we know that in fact,
what do we do?
Dell is doing now has been
done once before in the family,
her mother.
So a lot of things are hanging together.
The fact that Joel has a very
different height than can be explained.
The fact that you can require the
horse when nobody else in a poor work
community that can be explained as well.
A lot of things are falling
into place with USCIS.
A suspicion that's nuts
just sneaking up on us.
And I think that this is really why the
snake is so important to father is that
the discovery is knitting up on us.
It is sneaking up on everyone else.
This is a snake that is not,
um,
like the snake in, in, in
Dante, the snake that takes, um,
the possession of someone else. Although
there's an element of this as well.
But a snake that insinuates itself into
our consciousness and implore us to us,
the degree of knowledge or the kind of
knowledge that maybe we would prefer not
to have.
So this is really the very early snake,
the snake that is the bearer of knowledge
coming to Adam and eve, um, that,
that has been involved here.
Um,
and it's just too clearish the case just
to make everything very, very clear.
Um,
father now resource to
another epic invention,
um,
bringing at a back to life.
And so that she actually
gets to say something. Um,
and there is no other explanation
other than the license,
the piloting license afforded by
the antics form that will allow for,
uh,
a completely non realistic representation
of the voice of a dead person and
otherwise realistic novel.
But that is relative license that
thought and is taking. So in a very,
very strange moment,
basically at the very heart of SLA dying,
we see the voice of a addressing us and
talking about a past moment in her life,
I would think of sin as I was thinking
of the clues we both wore in the world's
phase of the suit inspection
necessary because he was a,
he and I was I to send the more other
and terrible since he was the instrument
or they by God who created the sin to
stand defy that sin he has created.
Why waited for him in the worst waiting
for him because he saw me before he saw
me. I would think of him
as stressed in stand here.
The more beautiful since the garment
which she had exchange with sin.
The sand defied, um, is um,
and the confession I guess as
close to her confession, um,
as we can gather about the
paternity of jewel. Uh,
but that confession about the paternity
of Julio is characteristically couch in
terms of a strange con of satisfaction,
um,
that any guests from this
particular kind of affair,
which is that the Garmin that her partner
in sin has exchange for that sin is
Ashley.
All the more beautiful because
it is sanctified by God.
So that houses who the father is running.
Um,
and um,
following as being tongue in cheek here,
the father we figure out is probably
which seal is the only likely candidate.
There's really no one else in that
small community of could be the father.
So they could only be one. Uh, but, um,
it turns out the Faulkner
naturally has taken his name, uh,
from a historic figure, a
fairly influential preacher. Um,
18th century. Appreciate
Benjamin Franklin. Um, send them,
when he would go to here with Phil,
he would make sure that he will have very
little money on this person because he
just know that he would empty out
his pockets. Uh, when he, when,
when he goes around and ask for donations.
And sure enough,
even though he takes very
little money with him,
he always walks away with empty
pockets after review was done.
So that's a very powerful one of the most
famous preachers of the 18th century.
Um, and Faulkner has
recreated this preacher, uh,
but with a twist and SLA dying.
And this is his with you.
It was his hand that bore me safely
about the float that fan at me from the
dangers of the waters. My horse
was frightened. Am I own hearts?
They only as the logs and the approved
the trees pour down upon my littleness,
but not my,
so I knew then that forgiveness was mine.
The flood,
the danger behind.
And as I rode on across the firm,
uh,
so,
um,
the bundling's unable to
cross the soul and river,
the muse
in the river,
one person is able to cross the river
because his horse is able to cross.
Um,
so this is the genealogy of the horse,
both as wholes and obviously
also is snake as well.
Full spectrum of meanings
of the creatures snake.
Um, uh, review to us in pieces.
And that is really the nature
of the narrative, right?
That we don't actually get
the whole picture all at once.
We see different bodily pause coming to
you with the emotion of this creature.
And uh, with this, um,
establish,
funnily establish kinship between Jews,
horse and with fields cause um,
in this case of very well behaved for
it's not a lot like the wild west of joule
was also explains why, um,
with you is a minister, uh,
whereas a Jewess nothing like that.
Um,
so it's the wireless in the offspring
that actually backwards reproduces the
mostly law abiding but not completely
law abiding identity of the father.
Um, and just to add to
that, um, here is down.
So then everything,
and this is the clearest indication that
the animal for Whitfield is also the
horse on a horse.
He rode out to arms stairs and came back
on the hoses almost too heavy handed to
emphasize this detail over and over again.
I would have been
completely uncalled for of,
except for the fact that we really need
to have a narrative genealogy for jaw.
And it is a narrative
genealogy that is tall Ashley.
Not through,
not only through a human story,
not only through the monologue
of, of, of, of, um, of added, um,
in this epic convention, uh,
of the desk speaking. Uh,
but there's also a parallel at the
convention of human story thread through
another human creature.